hello everyone welcome to a little Day
in the Life what a new day as a non-diet
[Music]
dietitian of course thank you so much to
thrive market for sponsoring this video
I'm currently on holiday in Florida with
my family though I am definitely still
working so I thought I would take you
guys with me on a random day of my Life
as a mom as an entrepreneur as a
dietitian as a perfectly imperfect human
just trying my best to balance it all
without burning out also huge disclaimer
that this is my diet on a random day it
is not meant to be duplicated it is not
meant to serve as some kind of
Instruction Manual of how you should eat
my needs are unique to myself and also
will change day-to-day just based on how
I'm feeling or what I'm doing so please
speak to register dietitian about your
unique needs
but first coffee actually truth be told
I've already had a latte this morning
plus some random leftover bites from my
kids breakfast it was a night last night
my kids were up about a million
gazillion
times Carol and the morning ended with
me putting my 3 and 1/2-year-old in the
car in the pitch black trying to drive
him around the neighborhood trying to
get him back to sleep like literally
haven't done that since my first son had
colic at 3 months so yeah if I'm not
forming sentences coherently today it's
because I haven't had a whole lot of
sleep and I'm also on like an ADHD
medication vacation as they call it
though also my viance was kind of
causing my hair to thin and fall out so
I DC that and I still have not found a
medication that does the job for me it
is a journey as a lot of you guys know
but the kids are out of the house so I'm
going to do a quick little floor workout
in the cramped space that I I have just
to get my body moving cuz I know that
I'll probably feel a lot more energized
and a little bit you know like I can
start my day on a good note if I get a
little joyful movement let's do it okay
this is not Mom life I don't know what
is so I have a few essentials that I
have here in Florida um since we come
here every year this is not my usual gym
I just try to get what I can done and
basically I use what I've got available
so I've got some little ankle weights
I've got a selection of bands here some
of which my kids have ripped because
they like to do their own floor workouts
AKA they just like basically try to
shoot these and launch them at each
other and then I have some very light
kind of Weights ooh these ones feel
heavy today I guess that means I'm
tired but you know what I say any
movement is good movement so let's get
her
[Music]
done okay not the most intense workout
but I feel better all right now it is
actually coffee time so let's get
caffeinated and make some breakfast so I
got a strange specific way I like my
coffee I do like 2/3 soy milk one3 unsed
almond milk and a little splash of this
uh oat caramel Mach macchiato creamer
yeah it's really delicious it doesn't
have a ton of sweetness I do not like
sweet things it just has like a hint of
Flav flavor and it's got 1 G of added
sugar I got this at TH Market too all
right let's
[Music]
try
okay I was needing a fullon hunger
crushing combo this morning because lack
of sleep always always makes me hungry
so I got my water I got my protein berry
smoothie situation I got my
L most important thing and okay here in
the States you guys have so many
different I don't know convenience
breakfast options and I'm seriously
obsessed with breakfast sausages so I
got these turkey Maple breakfast
sausages they've got N9 g of protein in
three which I thought was pretty good
and I love that you can put them the
microwave M it's so good okay so we talk
about my Hunger crush and combo a lot on
my channel and I know that is completely
revolutionized how so many of you think
about food and how you build a balanced
meal without restricting and a lot of
you will ask me okay Abby how much fiber
how much protein how many grams of fat
do I need and that's the thing this is
highly individualized and really will
depend on your unique body but also your
goals you know the beauty of working
within a framework like this is that
there aren't exact rules to follow there
aren't exact numbers that you need to be
abiding by if there was like that
doesn't even make sense that's why diets
don't necessarily work because there is
no one siiz fits all model so the beauty
of this is that you get to tweak it
based on how your body responds but
generally speaking for me at breakfast
protein is always my number one priority
as you can see I really need to focus on
protein and that is true for a lot of
folks I mean we have ample evidence that
having a protein Rich breakfast first
thing really helps to stabilize hunger
hormones and prevent over eating or you
know a ton of Cravings later on
throughout the day so yeah protein is
always going to be king in the satiety
hierarchy and is particularly important
if you're trying to lose weight or
manage your weight which obviously I'm
not but I know a lot of you watching may
be now
fiber also really important for me
especially me because I have ibsc
and basically I always find that my
digestion gets really thrown for a loop
when I travel and that's true for a lot
of folks so I I pay extra attention to
getting in fiber when I'm traveling and
then the fat really helps to contribute
the satisfaction with the satiety Factor
it really contributes to that feeling
like M you know I'm done now I can move
on that felt really good so for me
especially breakfast I really focus in
on getting all the components oh but my
husband is now calling me
probably an emergency with the children
so I'm going to go deal with that finish
my breakfast and I'll meet you on the
flip side okay daily supplements so one
of the things I like to do not just when
I'm traveling but in general is I put
like all my medication and my
supplements in a Pillow Pack a month at
a time so that way I only have to shlep
out all my medications and I have to
refill them only once a month and I
don't have to think about it constantly
it's such an ordeal if you have to shlep
everything out to to you know remember
everything you're trying to take at what
what time it's not realistic so if you
are trying to start a supplement regimen
and to stick to it as like a New Year's
resolution kind of situation pill packs
save the day it's like meal prep but for
your supplements you know what I'm
saying all right because I put them all
in at one time it's not like I I
probably can't even tell you what's
what's in here but I'll give you a sense
of generally what I take in the morning
omega-3 very important in general
because most people do not get enough
Omega-3s but especially important if you
have ADHD this is a vitamin D A I've got
a couple probiotics I've got a Spore
forming probiotics and Sacro mcces uh
probiotic of course I've got my um anti-
anxiety I've got uh Chase tree which is
for regulating my cycle and um oil of
oregano which is something I take every
day twice a day um as kind of like a
maintenance to prevent uh sibo
reoccurrence it's for my I yes so that's
kind of what I take generally in the day
for in morning time so yeah that's my
supplement regimen Please Do Not
Duplicate this this is not for anybody
else but for me based on extensive
research knowing my exact needs lots of
blood work knowing and understanding how
nutrition impacts all of my different
diagnoses so definitely work with a
register dietition if you're trying to
determine uh a supplement regimen for
yourself big disclaimer there okay folks
delivery time here let me tell you about
my sponsor Thrive market so this time of
year is very challenging for a lot of
people because you know we're extra
motivated to eat well and take care of
our bodies but the price of groceries
right now is kind of insane but if you
haven't heard about Thrive Market get
excited because it has really changed
the game for me Thrive Market is an
amazing online membership based grocery
store that aims to make Health focused
Specialty Products more affordable and
accessible to everyone they're a
One-Stop shop shop offering foods and
snacks eco-friendly kitchen and cleaning
supplies Beauty items supplements
HomeGoods and everything in between most
of the year I live in Canada but as soon
as I get here to the states I order my
Thrive box because there are just so
many amazing products that you really
cannot get anywhere else basically you
can filter by over 90 different diets
Lifestyles and values like vegan fair
trade gluten-free and more they have an
amazing selection of sustainable Seafood
wine and nutritious snacks that my kids
adore and every time I order I discover
a new handful of delicious products that
really just become Staples for us and
the best part is all of the items are
less expensive than traditional retail
they price match and members make back
their annual $60 membership in savings
and for whatever reason you don't Thrive
will credit you the difference I also
love their commitment to sustainability
not only a shipping on orders over $49
free but everything is delivered with
carbon neutral shipping and from their
zero waste warehouses another thing I
really love about Thrive is that for
every paid annual membership the Thrive
gives initiative gives away a free
membership to a lowincome family teacher
Andor veteran there's really so many
reasons to feel good about ordering from
Thrive so if you want to save some money
on really unique healthy products this
year check out the link in my
description Thrive market.com slabby
sharp to get 30% off of your first order
and a free gift worth up to $60 okay so
I know I'm supposed to be on holiday
right now but this is going to be one of
the most chaotic months of my entire
career I am weeks away of the pre-launch
of something that I hope you guys know
about by now and if you don't it's
probably because I've hit my 10,000th
roadblock and I'm about to murder
someone but I will not be bullied
[Music]
by also I'm pitching my second book
right now which if you guys don't know
if you're new here if you haven't been
around for the last few years my
cookbook the mindful CL cookbook is
celebrating its 5year anniversary which
is crazy that that was 5 years ago and I
have another very exciting Venture that
I'm working on right now I don't think I
can talk about it yet but hopefully very
very very soon I don't know all of this
cryptic will make sense soon hopefully
if it doesn't already but meanwhile
there is like so much website
copyrighting and approvals and scripts
and content planning honestly I need a
clone I asked for one for Chris mup but
I did not get it it was disappointing to
say the least let's get to it okay so
one of the things I've learned um over
the past few months about my ADHD is
that I really need to take frequent
movement breaks throughout the day if I
want to be able to like work and be
efficient with my work so I thought I'd
kind of go for a little walk down the
street picked myself up some lunch I
could have made lunch myself obviously
but a as we've established tired okay
and I've got too many things to do I'd
rather spend this time with my kids than
making myself every single meal in the
day from scratch not to mention I find
like whenever we're traveling most of
what's in the fridge is like breakfast
foods and snacks and foods that are for
specific family dinner meals so
typically when we're traveling I will do
like one meal out a day right so whether
it's breakfast lunch dinner we're
usually home for dinners we go out a
couple times a week Max but it's harder
with the kids yeah it often becomes too
wasteful to make every single meal from
scratch because I don't have every spice
that I need I don't have every condiment
that I need you know it just gets too
wasteful otherwise when you don't have a
solid routine and plan and I was craving
me some Greek salad let's sit down I
love the Greek salad from this place
it's that's we've been going to for
years but I love that they have the
chickpeas in in here for plant-based
protein plus the chicken so I kind of
have like a double dose double duty
situation going on super
satiating and I will eat anything with
feta on it honestly you can give me a
rubber shoe I will eat it if you give me
enough feta one thing I don't love
though is all this styrofoam and plastic
like Florida get with the times you
can't even buy a plastic bag back home
in Canada never mind get like every
single drink and take out and plastic
and styrofoam it's not good it's not
good that's one thing that kind of turns
me off of ordering in all the time when
I'm traveling but generally speaking I
usually try to get in like a salad a day
whether it's like a meal salad or a side
salad especially at lunch because like I
said you know fiber is typically harder
to get in when you're traveling and I'm
always craving fresh crunchy cold salads
when it's hot outside in Florida I don't
always have the same cravings when I'm
like at home freezing my buns off in the
Toronto blizzard of a winter but I'm not
going to make you watch me eat this
whole thing I don't know if you're
anything like my husband you probably
want to murder me from the crunching so
we will put that on
you much
later I crushed
that I don't like raw Tomatoes kill me
okay tomatoes and salad gross it's just
like slime and salad please argue with
me in the comments but yeah most
tomatoes are not good right if I get a
tomato from
if I'm in Italy I'm eating the tomatoes
but yeah here in
Canada that said your girl cannot live
on salad alone and while I feel satiated
I'm feeling not 100% satisfied because I
didn't really have any carbs here so I
went to my kids snack stash they seem to
like these they're called yes bars yes
please they got nuts dried fruit seeds
spices 3 G of fiber 5 g of plant-fed
protein M that actually really
good and just enough sweetness to really
like give me that
sweet end of a meal kind of experiment
that good okay so I got a couple calls I
got to get to I just got a million
emails come through where is hitting the
fan so if you don't know what projects
I'm talking about by the time this video
goes live it's because we've hit another
big roadblock but yeah I'm going to go
see the kiddos in a few hours so I
really got to get this stuff done but
you know the reason I don't show my kids
here is because I am vehemently against
family vlogging or really sharing any
identifying information about children
on the internet without their consent
and as far as I'm concerned a three and
a 5-year-old cannot really consent to
being Instagram influencers it doesn't
matter if you have a 100 followers or
100,000 followers the internet is not a
safe place not to mention my kids never
consented to being part of my content I
have no right to profit off of them like
I see so many family vloggers do I
really want them to build their own
online identities when they are ready to
do so not for the whole world to know
everything about them before they even
hit puberty it's gross so yeah it is a
hard no for me but I will humble brag
for a minut
look at
this my 5-year-old made this all by
himself it's a a 9-year-old Lego project
he did it all by himself in less than
you know a couple hours per day for 2
days I was really hoping this was going
to last our entire vacation because it's
expensive it's like a 900 piece Lego kit
uh but no he just blasted through it and
I can't even read one page of
instructions so you're have no benefit
at all move down to the to I got
it okay I'm sorry am I in your
way yeah that's the most you're going to
get from me about my kids until they're
ready to have their own channel which I
will definitely discourage all right it
is officially mom o00 I'm going to go
catch up with the kiddos at the beach
for a few before I head back to make
[Music]
dinner
all right folks let's make dinner we're
going to do one of like an Abby staple I
guess you could say this is like one of
the easiest meals that I make for my
family it's probably also one of my
personal favorites so we're going to do
brace cabbage and apples with barbecue
chicken sausages and with some roasted
potatoes this is my favorite my kids
love them my kids call them Mama
potatoes that's apparently what a
signature move they've
become look look how cute these are
they're nibblers they call them so sweet
all right let's boil those so I just
boil them until they're fork tender dice
them in half or/ quars and normally I
pan fry them with some butter in a cast
iron skillet at home but I don't have
one here so I just throw them onto a
baking sheet and I added a little melted
butter and lots of FLIR toell and I
roasted it at 450° freeze until golden
brown normally I might sauté an onion
here but I am working with the bare bone
holiday kitchen situation so I just
throw in a head of shredded cabbage
straight into the pot add a little bit
of water finally dice a green apple and
add that in add lots of pepper salt
balsamic vinegar and balsamic glaze and
a little maple syrup and I pop the lid
on until it simmers you got to taste
it m oh I forgot got the mustard very
important I usually do like a straight
up grainy Dijon and like lots of it but
I don't have that here so we're doing oo
honey mustard which just went on the
floor behind me
nice smells so
good okay so these say keep
frozen and you can just toss it on the
grill cuz they're already cooked which
we love
but yeah one link has 13 g of protein
amazing and my picky
toddler does love chicken sausages so
hopefully this will be a
hit it's windy
today I'm going to miss barbecuing in
January Floridians you got some good
weather I'll give you that okay but
random Canadian thought here please tell
me I'm not alone in this but does
anybody else feel like the shape of
Florida looks like a every single time I
see a sign with like the Florida outline
on it driving down the A1A I literally
think it's an upside down and I'm like
what are we allowed to shoot on this
highway not shoot on this highway I mean
what is happening here but no it's just
Florida anyone
else well the sausages look good this
Grill has seen better days despite how
much I try to clean
it okay dinner is served I'm going to
ring the
old Dinner Bell what the you can tell
that I'm tired right and get the old
kids in here so I'm going to sign off
before they start making their
appearances because # privacy and I'll
meet you after the kids go to bed also I
just realized that I had pre-cooked
chicken sausages twice today um I had
the breakfast ones and then I had these
but judging myself for taking cooking
shortcuts on my holiday is literally the
last thing I'm going to do plus I'm
super proud of myself for fueling my
body with lots of satiating protein and
colorful fruits and veg let's not be so
Harden ourselves I think this is a great
meal all right get unready with me my
skincare routine while I'm away is not
exactly what it is at home I've got a
lot more products including some
prescriptions retinol I don't really use
retinol here oh my goodness let get
ready for the most unflattering light in
this bathroom of all time but what I'm
using here is the proven um cleanser
they sponsored one of my videos and so I
really got into using their products and
actually they've been working really
great for me so love that for us I don't
have clean face gloth so don't judge me
I'm just going to ruin this towel with
all my makeup if you have sensitive skin
or sensitive eyes I really like this
makeup remover and also it's small so
it's easy to bring with me but it's more
like a bomb so it's like a cream doesn't
dry out your eyes or your
skin get ready for raccoon eyes five 4 3
two
one oh yeah that is
scary all right Next Step currently I'm
using this Face Serum by naked and
thriving I really like the texture I
switch it up though I mean I get sent so
many great products so basically every
few weeks I'm trying something new so as
long as it doesn't cause any adverse
effects I'm just going to go with the
flow go with what they send me really I
don't have to buy a lot what else oh
this is my eye cream
Sho everything's my fingers are so
greasy I can barely open up my you got
to grease like if you don't look like a
glazed Crispy Cream you're not doing it
right you're not doing it right and then
this is the triple lipid skin sual
Glazer up
baby all right I'm time for a snack okay
kids are down for now until somebody has
a nightmare for the millionth time but
I've taken my supplements and my sleep
medication basically the only difference
from the morning till now is I take
magnesium before bed and then I always
take my fiber supplement before bed as
well again because I have ibsc really
important for me I got
my Essential reading as a Swifty and I
always have a pretty substantial bedtime
snack something that's got protein fiber
and healthy fats AKA my Hunger crushing
combo and that's because I have a really
severe history of insomnia and the last
thing I ever want to do is to wake up in
the middle of the night hungry cuz it
really can throw me for a loop and it
really can just like throw off my whole
routine and it can take weeks to get
back on track I've got Greek yogurt here
I either do Greek yogurt or C cheese
before bed typically is my protein
source with some uh fiber rich fruit and
uh puffins which is one of my favorite
higher fiber cereals and then I got this
snack mix from Thrive as well and it
looks really really yummy so I'm going
to check that out I always like to have
um like a shelf staple snack beside my
bed just in case I do get hungry the
worst thing is having to get out of bed
going to the fridge opening up that
bright fridge it really just screws up
your circadian rhythm
so
yeah it's got like dried fruit in
it super crunchy I was like what does
uniquely crunchy mean these are very
crunchy I guess cuz they're sprouted M
Holo core crunch very
cool well on that note guys that is all
that I have for you today I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
leave me a comment below and like this
video if you want to see more of these
real life Day in the Life what in days
just a slice of life situations let me
know don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Na's kitchen
[Music]
bye